[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think that Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers will answer your question give
abuse advice and vu although excuse from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon John what is
the elephant in the room I mean I'm sure
we're gonna have the same help in the
room this week we'll give it a go anyway
three are you one just no we did just
find out that Justice Kennedy is
retiring which is a bummer but the
important news of the week my bean a
bummer I I don't even I don't even know
how to talk about the Supreme Court
right now Hank so I'm not gonna try
instead I'm gonna talk about the amazing
drama of the World Cup this this weird
timeline in which we find ourselves in
the multiverse Hank where so many things
are not great but sports just continues
to deliver a Chicago Cubs World Series
AFC Wimbledon promoted to the third tier
of English football
Liverpool oh so close to a Champions
League victory and then this year's
World Cup is Jay's the best world cup of
my lifetime by a wide margin despite the
fact that my home nation is not even
involved in it the drama is incredible I
almost barfed a couple hours ago
watching the World Cup that's how
stressful and exciting it was I gotta
tell you John oh my Twitter feed most of
the news today has been about like slack
being down I'm not I haven't I haven't
caught a great deal of World Cup news
except something to do with Germany not
being in the World Cup anymore that's
right Germany failed to qualify for the
knockout rounds Sharon and who helps
produce this podcast huge fan of the
German national team absolutely
devastated on the other hand my loyalty
is split because the pride of North
America Mexico qualified only because
Germany didn't college oh so I have to
confess that I was excited about that
excited for rosianna and also excited
for North America but yet you know 31
teams are gonna lose the World Cup this
year Hank alright and they all did
better than America that's right and
they can go home feeling good about that
so as Mexico in the NOC they qualified
for the knockout rounds are today or
even up nope they're in the round of 16
by the time this pod gets uploaded they
may be out of the World Cup it hasn't
they have to play a game to see if they
get to the next round well now it's now
it's the knockout round so called every
game is win or go home oh I thought the
knockout round was like sometimes in in
some sports you have a time when it's
like the the people who didn't do well
get to play each other to stay in the
tournament no no we don't have that no
that's not a thing okay so it's the
Niners a third-place game if you make it
to the semi-finals you get to play to
figure out who finishes third it's the
bummer wrist game in the World Cup every
year but anyway Hank let's not talk
about football or the Supreme Court
let's answer some questions from our
listeners John if there was any sport
before we get to questions from our
listeners if there was any sport that
you could have be as big a deal as
soccer that isn't currently as big a
deal as soccer what sport we happy um
can I pick soccer in the United States
no no I okay that's not in the spirit of
the question John I come up with it let
me come up with an answer I think it
would be amazing if the entire world
were captivated every four years by a
team handball global tournament all the
things I just think it would be amazing
or possibly table tennis yeah what about
if there was a building of table tennis
what about that game were that they play
and somewhere where it's like volleyball
but you have to use your feet you can't
use your hands
yeah foot volleyball I think that's the
technical term for it that's good that
would be really good I actually you know
I I played like the only game that I
except for hockey that I ever played
with any amount of gusto was Ultimate
Frisbee and do I feel like why not why
not the world cup of Ultimate Frisbee
indeed I think that professional
Ultimate Frisbee is incredible to talk
about drama I mean at what it's a heck
of a good sport the way I played it in
high school not quite as beautiful but
still there are so many great sports out
there that don't get the attention that
they deserve what about like robotics
you know like this
High School Robotics team I'd love to
see that in the Olympics is there an
Olympic is there a sport Hank in which
either current you or some past version
of you would have had a legitimate
chance of making it to the Olympics ah
like video blogging maybe mmm I don't
think so I don't know my god
maybe 2008 you could have made it to the
Olympics and video blogging maybe right
right because there just was a lot of
competition right the American the
American bench was pretty weak by I
don't know I think so much yeah
sometimes I think like am I good you
know oh I have it I could be I could go
totally go to the World Cup for singing
fast about science
oh that's very yes that's good that's
good I mean I'm definitely in the top
and that because just because there's as
we say not a huge pool right it's
important to be my friend Amy Karl's
rosenthal told me once that it more than
being important to excel at something
it's important to excel at something
extremely specific and I find that to be
really deeply advisor
let's answer some questions from our
listeners this one comes from Josh who
writes Dear John and Hank after getting
the chance to live with my sister for a
few years in our mid-20s we've become
very close this is a great gift because
we didn't have the best relationship
growing up this past year I got engaged
and purchased a house which has led to
less contact and communication with my
sister most of our recent communications
has become sharing YouTube videos with
each other while I should be happy that
we have a good relationship and enjoy
the same things like any older sibling
I'm more concerned about who should get
credit for discovering those videos is
the discoverer of new content the person
who have used it first or the person who
shares it first whoever's wrong has to
buy the other a copy of an absolutely
remarkable things which comes out
September 25th and is available for
pre-order now just meaning around
Josh PS the wedding is on March 17th
just north of Boston and you are both
invited Hank I took the liberty of going
to Josh's wedding website he didn't give
us that much information but he did give
us enough information because Google is
creepy for me to find his wedding
website where he's wearing a we're the
exception Mongols crash-course t-shirt
thank you for supporting us over at
dftba.com Josh but the relevant thing
here Hank before we get to the question
is that on their website there's a big
button that says menu and then it says
our wedding and then underneath that it
says details and I went to details of
course because I want to know like you
know where is the wedding can i
realistically go etc I click details
there is nothing there's there's nothing
under the details menu Hank and then
there's no photos under the photos thing
and then they don't even have a registry
up Josh for the love of God get your
registry on the internet man I wanted to
buy you're gonna send your wedding
information to of a famous author who
might want to buy you a crock-pot or
something you gotta have that up there I
mean you you want me to like bookmark
the page and keep visiting every day
until you update your registry because I
will if necessary Josh put some detail
of the details tab of your wedding
website how did this question this this
fine question about asking who gets the
credit for discovering a video devolve
and do you criticize in someone's
wedding website which clearly is not the
most important website on the internet I
mean it's the most important website
related to Josh's wedding on the
internet that's true that's true and and
it is it does but it doesn't make me
feel a little bit like I don't have a
ton of faith that they're gonna put on
the the most sort of like well-run like
well clockwork wedding to be fair their
wedding is not for 263 days it is a
while from now yes true it is a while
from now John do you have any examples
of like a YouTube video that you feel
like you you found before everyone and
you were like this is gonna be big and
then it became big yes the history of
Japan video by Bill words yes I saw when
it had like fewer than 10,000 views and
I I watched it and I sent it to Sarah
and Sarah was like this is great and
when Sarah likes a YouTube video I know
it's gonna be real big I once watched it
I fairly recently watched a video that I
said I tweeted in that so this is gonna
this is gonna be huge and then it wasn't
oh really
was it which is pretty regular for me
actually I
I tend to think that uh that it's easier
to go viral than it actually is John yes
it is not that easy to go viral
especially now the internet now contains
I don't know if you've noticed this a
lot of videos indeed indeed an
occasionally you see something and
you're like this is this is gonna do it
and then it actually does and that
always feels good when you when you
tweet it early and and I think that
there is some there is some cred that
you get for that some status you could
sort of achieve when it's like I am I
wasn't I don't know
and should you though cuz he didn't make
the video and also like it wasn't you
that made it go viral right but you know
there is something that feels good about
being liked among the first 1000
subscribers to a new YouTube channel or
the first 1000 people to see a video
that ends up going huge or listening to
somebody's mixtape before they you know
blow up or whatever there is something
fun about that that said the person who
gets credit for the video is the person
who shares it not sure I see it yeah
absolutely you got to do the share yeah
because because otherwise you could just
be lying like you gotta go show me
you're like a screenshot of your YouTube
history you might be just adding editing
the HTML I can't believe you I don't
have any reason to trust you Josh also
on the 2018 Internet if it didn't get
shared it literally didn't happen yeah
that's yeah shares Scherzer didn't
happen I I can't trust anything anymore
so if I didn't see if I didn't see an
email from Josh then then I I trust I
trust no one
yeah I mean I don't even I don't even
like God I Hank how did we get how did
we get to this dark timeline sorry
what's the next question this next
question comes from Alex John it says
hey Hank and John hi hey yeah super cash
cash alex says I say like a lot as do my
friends as to you guys it's true we do
say like but whenever I go home my mom
makes like a big deal of it some doesn't
say like I just inserted alike because
that's what I do sometimes stopping the
conversation whenever I say
like I never noticed it until she points
it out and now I really listen to what I
say is it just a normal part of our
language now do you notice yourself
doing it all the time pumpkins and
Penguins Alex your mom's just harshing
your buzz ma'am yes I mean Marsha is
young yes buddy
harsh it on your gums it's not cool
here's the thing about like if you don't
say like you either say said constantly
right or you don't have those weird
pauses in your speech which I think
makes your speech sound more weird at
least to me like there's a reason we say
like and it's to create a pause it's to
create a moment for us to think but also
to create a moment between whatever we
just said and one we're like about to
say and then the other way you use like
is when you say like that
like the person was like I'm so tired
and then the other person was like I'm
also tired post VidCon and then a third
person was like well I'm tired of trying
to brave the onslaught of horrors that I
see from the social Internet and I'm
disgusted and despondent with the state
of discourse in the United States and
those people didn't maybe literally say
those things and that's why you say like
is because you're not actually quoting
someone you're trying to deliver the
content of what they said or at least of
what you heard so I actually think that
like plays a good role in our language
yeah I think definitely there are times
that I listen to someone talk and I
think to myself that's too many likes
sure but but I I use it as an um I also
um and we're professional talkers on
this podcast if we am i doing it
semi-pro semi professional talkers if
we're doing it and people are okay with
it I think it's probably okay at this
point so you can tell your mom that
instead of saying like you were not
gonna say shirk all the time and she's
gonna have to deal with that and you and
you'll be you'll be shirk mom I am just
gonna say firk all the time now right
nobody wants to hear and then
she was shirk I can't believe Germany
didn't qualify for the knockout round
well then you can't tell right now I'm
very sleepy
yes dig for a little bit of slur enos in
my vocal patterns and and if you could
see me you you would be like that guy
needs some rest and you'd be right yeah
all right our next question comes from
timoni who asks Dear John and Hank after
so many times that I've had deadlines
for papers at 11:59 p.m.
I've started to wonder how did people
live without being able to check the
time so easily how did people tell time
before clocks when you wanted to meet
someone did you just wait around all day
or hope you randomly bumped into them at
some point also it would be a cool
challenge to try to go the whole day
without checking the time in a place
without much sunshine it's time to get
an absolutely remarkable thing to mow me
John when I read this question I thought
to myself here's the thought I had how
do you turn in a paper at 11:59 p.m. I
also had that thought I was like are you
like rushing across campus and then I
realized oh right we when we turned in
papers when we went to school we handed
them to the professor on the day they
were due wouldn't the class happened
absolutely 100% with our hands do at the
beginning of class occasionally things
would be due at 11:59 p.m. I guess but
you know only when I was turning them in
late right
I never remember doing anything at 11:00
and also this is sort of like it's
hilarious to me that that a professor is
like sitting there at their desks being
like it's 11:58 to about to get a bunch
of papers on us all so you've literally
waited to the last minute
litora right oh I feel like nothing
inspires a lack of confidence in a
professor quite like reading a paper
that was turned in at 11:59 p.m. in 42
seconds you know like what that screams
to me is I was not prepared
this is not done is what it says to me
it says this is as close as I could get
yeah no absolutely what did people do
before well that's an interesting
question so in a lot of places there
still isn't the same time obsession that
we have in here in the United States and
we didn't have it in most of the world
or any of the world really before the
Industrial Revolution when people
started clocking in to work when there
started to be a lot of workers who were
no longer agricultural workers whose
days weren't determined by you know by
sunshine but instead by by hours so I
think that was kind of the beginning of
the change but in lots of places in the
world you still see time dealt with
differently and in a lot of cases that
means you have an appointment for the
afternoon and you don't know exactly
when in the afternoon it will be the
like obsession with minute by minute
punctuality is definitely not a global
phenomenon but it is a big part of my
personal life I mean it's definitely
more efficient and I think that like the
the Act the Industrial Revolution had a
strong focus on understanding efficiency
as a thing like even understanding that
that that is is a thing and also
understanding that sort of a virtue and
sort of I also like it sort of is
remarkable to me to think that like I am
not actually a slave to the clock and I
feel a little bit as if I am because of
course like my meetings start usually on
the hour and then go for a half an hour
or 50 minutes or something and so I I am
paying attention all the time to that
thing but but with if when that thing
goes away you are still you still have
to do the work and so what did how do
people like decide when they had to get
up it wasn't like odd 6:00 a.m. I have
to get up boys it was like the works not
gonna get done and then I'm gonna be
hungry right or not get paid or not get
like like my family will not be taken
care of right I do sometimes wish that I
were not
clock focused as I am and even when I
was a kid I remember looking at the
clock much less because I didn't own a
watch and obviously there were no
smartphones and so you know lots of
times I wouldn't know what time it is
these days I can usually at least during
the day tell you what time it is within
10 minutes just by thinking without
looking at a clock and that's a little
distressing to me because yeah you're
right that the Industrial Revolution put
a great emphasis on efficiency and the
value of efficiency but also in a way it
created this idea that our lives exist
to run efficiently and to like fill
needs in marketplaces and it's a little
disturbing to me because sometimes I
wonder does the market exist to make
people better or do people only exist to
make the markets more efficient and then
the last thing I will add I'm not gonna
add anything to that particular line of
thinking but there was a time when
clocks had to be quite large and so you
could have like a big one in your house
but you certainly weren't gonna get one
on your wrist and during that period of
time it was like well how are we gonna
have everybody know sort of roughly what
time it is and if you're trying to try
to solve that problem one way to do it
would be to build a very large clock
that you could see from far away and or
ring a bell at every hour for the number
of like in like ring four bells if it's
four o'clock which is why that happens
and it's sort of weird to think like
this is just a thing that happens we
don't need this we continue to do it but
at one point it was a very important
part of like everybody would being on
the same page base there's a clock tower
by my house that rings on the hour and I
still love that and it reminds me of
when I was in college you were not
considered late until the clock tower
had banged for the last time so if it
was 11:00 and you got there before the
11th Bing you were on time I loved and
then one o'clock and it starts to get a
lot more tight exactly I tried to
schedule online classes for 11:00 to
save that six seconds because I'm so
time obsessed this next question comes
from Kim who writes Dear John and Hank I
live in southern Florida
the trail near my house that I use for
exercise borders a wetland Preserve I've
seen alligators along this stretch while
driving and I've had to go around
poisonous snakes on the sidewalk while
biking as a native Floridian I
understand that these animals would like
to avoid me as much as I would like to
avoid them and how to keep a respectful
distance however there is a definite
level of vigilance that is absent when I
exercise elsewhere my question is does
this primal fear help me burn more
calories or otherwise improve my workout
reptiles and rollerblades Kim if there's
actually rollerblades involved you
really should have led with that because
the idea of you like jumping and skating
around a bunch of like coral snakes just
really makes my day right I'm also
seeing you like do do a jump off the
back of an alligator like it's a ramp
just like this I feel like Kim maybe you
should have some kind of 90's animated
15 or 11 minute vide TV series that
would be great yeah I'm here for that I
absolutely I also think that yeah in
general anything that motivates you to
ride your bike faster is good and the
fear of death probably is providing that
I think you definitely get an adrenaline
boost from that like I've run and barely
missed a snake before like with my foot
fall oh really and after like five
minutes after that I was definitely
running faster now I don't know that it
increased my overall time because for
like four five minutes after that I was
running slower because I was tired but I
do think that getting an adrenaline
boost it can't hurt so I would say get
as close to those alligators as you can
I mean actually right like encourage
them to bite because that's gonna be a
big adrenaline boost yeah you got to get
a hungry alligator it's not just a like
it's race or or your family you could be
like hey y'all if you could go and like
lay down some fake snakes mmm on my on
my rollerblading route I won't know the
difference because I won't know for sure
if they're real or not but make sure you
you don't think don't think like oh
these are probably fake because they
might not be they might be real you
don't know which ones are faking which
ones are real and you don't want to
skate over one of them and suddenly have
it attached like stuck in your wheels
what will wiggling around wobbling
around covered in
it's scales and teeth you ever wondered
what Hank is like when he's really tired
you just heard oh man I'm so tired my
body is very confused I took a nap at 9
a.m. today who's not long enough I
should have napped more this next
question comes from Brent who asks dear
Hank and John I have a dilemma I'm an
artist in high school and I routinely
recently opened Commission's where I
draw people or their pets for money
shortly after I posted them my
Commission's were up and I got messages
from two different people who are
interested but these people are dating
each other as it's their one-year
anniversary soon and they each want a
drawing of them together to give to the
other person this is an issue I can't
exactly tell either of them because it's
a gift but I don't want to have them
both pay for the same thing that feels
like a scam helps it's not what it's not
the same thing you got to make two
different artworks - yes rdy artworks -
arts yes - arts I got paid to do two
arts due to arts and that it's super
adorable because then they both get an
art that's different but it's from the
same artist because they that's so cute
yeah you got to do it I would propose
though that you do two vastly different
arts so in one of the drawings you have
like the couple at Hogwarts and he's a
Gryffindor and she's a ravenclaw and
they're riding their brooms playing
Quidditch against each other and then in
the other one
it's like 1972 in Los Angeles and
they're just learning how to skate and
yeah sure that those votes sound great I
was I was still stuck in Florida and
snakes and just covered in snakes but
that's way less good than learning how
to skateboard in the 70s in Los Angeles
that sounds off I have a romantic drive
for you it's super romantic it's a
picture of the two of us covered in
snakes picture of the two of us at the
World Cup of Ultimate Frisbee which
reminds me that today's podcast is
brought to you by the World Cup of
Ultimate Frisbee the world cup of
Ultimate Frisbee just you will not
believe the frisbee catches involved
ultimate frizz
extravaganza this podcast is also
brought to you by the word shirk that's
what you say instead of like always from
now on just to make your mom know that
she's being a pill and today's podcast
is also brought to you by 11:59 p.m.
11:59 p.m. a non ideal time to turn in
your paper and finally this podcast is
brought to you by incomplete wedding
website Josh get with it Josh come on
there's only 259 days left to go
only 259 days left to get this podcast
is also brought to you by our actual
sponsor audible thank you all thank the
Lord for audible oh man both because
you're being sponsors and but and also
because when I haven't been having a
hard time sleeping because I might be
stressed out about an event that's going
on at the moment even though it's going
very well I've still need a little bit
of somebody talking in my ears about
space space exploration or about fantasy
London in in 1820 like anything will
play really helps put me to sleep and
also helps me hear some great stories
audible is where you go for all kinds of
audio entertainment and right now if you
go to audible.com slash dear Hank or if
you text dear Hank to 500 500 you'll get
a 30 day free trial your first audio
book is a free and among the free audio
books that you can get are my books The
Fault in Our Stars or Paper Towns or
Turtles all the way down or Looking for
Alaska or the other one that no one
reads you can get all of those really
high quality audio books I love the
narrator's for all of my books I feel so
lucky to have had such great narrators
and you can get any of them for free or
any other book you want you can also
pre-order an absolutely remarkable thing
on audible that's audible.com slash Dear
John that's my recommended URL
audible.com slash Dear John or you can
send a text message to five hundred five
hundred that just reads Dear John and
sign up get a 30 day free trial in your
first audio book free audible really is
an amazing amazing service I love
listening to audiobooks Hank I don't
know if you're listening to anything
right now but I just love I am
audiobooks so much I'm listening to too
right now I'm listening to too because
one of them is scary books I don't like
to listen to it when I'm going to sleep
called slate house mmm it's by David
Mitchell it's really interesting and
good but when I'm it's dark in my room
and I have my headphones in and I'm
staring at my nightstand without being
able to close my eyes because it's so
creepy and cool I don't like that so I'm
also listening to
Babylon's ashes which is a James sa
Corey expanse novel there are lots of
experience novels and they're all very
good and they all have audiobooks and
thank the Lord they all have the same
narrator because I hate it when
narration changes from book to book when
it's a series audible carries titles in
every genre you can imagine from
business to the classics to history to
romance to sci-fi to kids and young
adult books it's great so go to
audible.com slash Dear John or text Dear
John to 500 500 thank you again to
audible for sponsoring today's episode
Hank I have to say one thing which is
about David Mitchell he wrote a book
called Black Swan green that is one of
my all-time favorite novels about
adolescence so if you like that David
Mitchell book I really suggest that you
read Black Swan green or listen to it
alright thanks this next question John
it comes from Elle who asks dear Hank
and John the group of girls I've been
friends with best friends with since
eighth grade is planning a trip to
Europe next year as a graduation
celebration my issue I don't want to go
I love my friends and all but I don't
think I want to spend four weeks living
in hostels with them especially because
it might be a stretch for me to afford
due to my tendency to accept unpaid
internships situation is further
complicated by the fact that my
ex-girlfriend will be along on the trip
as well on the other hand part of me
wants to go anyway so I don't miss out
on these possible amazing memories how
do I tell my friends I don't want to go
or should I just go and bear the
discomfort out of a fear of missing out
in distress ell you should go well yeah
I think I think you should go yeah
you're gonna tell so I also feel that
way I think you should go and I do think
that there will be parts of it that are
um
durable but I also think that in ten
years you won't be able to go to Europe
and live in hostels for a month for a
variety of reasons one of which is that
you will have developed a pretty serious
aversion to body lice bite you gotta go
ah I was thinking just you know the
normal aches and pains of being thirty
but but also that I think I think
probably L might now have a pretty
serious aversion to body lice the good
news is it's manageable it's true it's
not fatal Elsa don't worry about it the
hostels no I I think it's I think it's
such a great opportunity and you
probably don't know how fun it will be
until you go and it ready stressful and
scary but it will also be many other
things and the memories that you will
make on that trip I think are really
valuable and so obviously Hank and I
don't actually know what your situation
is and it may be that you just can't
bear to go and you really can't afford
to go in which case maybe don't but I
think I think you should go yeah all
things being equal not knowing a ton
about the situation yeah I feel the same
ol way all right Hank mm-hmm we got a
lot of questions this week about u.s.
immigration policy and I want to ask one
of them this one comes from who Lisa who
writes dear John and Hank i live in
McAllen a city at the texas-mexico
border with a Hispanic population that
makes up the vast majority of the city
I'm very fortunate I'm going to college
and will be applying to medical school
next summer I had a great cultural
upbringing my parents are both of
Mexican descent and I would not have
chosen to have been raised anywhere else
in any way else however when it began
hearing about the detention centers in
cities at the border I discovered much
to my horror that one of the largest if
not the largest detention center for
undocumented immigrant children is in my
city actually down the street from where
my sister goes to high school it's very
hard for me to watch the videos of the
detention centers because the people in
them are the same types of people that I
see at home or college or at the grocery
store they're just people who were born
half an hour away and for trying to live
that half an hour up north they're
having their families torn apart and
their kids put in cells yet as much as
I'm nauseated and deeply saddened by
what has happened
in my city I feel a sense of defeat as
if there's nothing aside from
volunteering and running supply drives
which I'm already taking part in that I
can do to stop this administration in
their quest to stop this administration
in their quest for wins at politics any
advice on how to stay optimistic and
feel like my voice still matters in
these dark times French the llama ELISA
I really don't know like I'm definitely
struggling with this but but I do want
to say that just by writing in and
giving us that perspective from a city
whoo from a person who lives in that
city is very helpful like it's that that
is a voice that you know we're
perspective that I haven't heard a lot
from you know and so that that's nice
for me to have and something that like
I'm glad that you could provide for us
yeah it is really difficult right now
and I don't have any solutions I don't
know how to change our political life in
the United States except by voting and
so I would really strongly encourage if
you are seventeen and a half and you are
gonna turn 18 before November if you're
23 and you've never voted because you
don't think it's important it is
important it does matter it matters
ultimately more than all the
billionaires spending all of the money
trying to push policy this way or that
that you can't let those people decide
who gets to determine the future of our
country so please vote the argument that
I see on the other side of this Hank and
I have tried to pay attention to that
argument is that we can't be a nation
without borders and that somehow people
on the Left want us to be a nation
without borders I think that's just
completely untrue
I I think that that is a straw man
argument I haven't heard anybody say
that we shouldn't have borders there is
a difference between having borders and
separating families at those borders
there is a difference between having
borders and denying people their
international right to claim asylum and
the people people who come to this
country whether they are citizens or not
whether they are documented immigrants
or not they deserve due process under
the law
that is guaranteed them in the
Constitution and to me this is not a
left-right issue and I think it's really
important if we can to stand up as a
country and say this is not a left-right
issue and refuse to accept it and I I
don't know what else we can do other
than that I am also frustrated and
scared and overwhelmed and I am so so
sorry
to the people that this directly affects
because I know yeah I'm not one of those
people
but I'm only not one of those people
because I won a birth lottery mm-hmm and
I I came into you know the days before
VidCon this was all sort of happening
and as we arrived at VidCon you were
like well Trump signed an executive
order that's gonna do something I guess
and and it just makes it like it's sort
of these additional complexities that
it's like well what does this mean
are those film is gonna be reunited have
they been what's the process through
which that happens suddenly it becomes
like you just add these little
complexities until people stop paying
attention right and I just I feel like
that's done over and over again and it's
intentional to try and make people feel
like well I guess I'm not sure I guess
I'm not sure what the situation is
because I'm not sure who's in the right
here right same thing is done with when
it comes to gun control legislation
things are brought up and nuances are
explored and then I do think there has
been some change in the US as policy
toward people coming to the United
States but there are too many families
that have not been reunited and it is
completely unacceptable yeah and so is
the amount of just not telling the truth
it it is so difficult it is so difficult
to have conversations with people who
won't engage with reality I just don't I
don't know what to do with this yeah
like I mean you see the president over
and over again saying that crime in
Germany is going up and it isn't that is
a lie
crime in Germany is going down by the
way crime in the United States is also
going down so I I would think that the
president would want to take credit for
that but I think what the president
really wants to do is make people
afraid and the truth that crime in the
United States is declining as it has
been for 40 years is not something that
will make people afraid and so it
doesn't get any doesn't get any emphasis
I've got a one that's a little bit more
light it's from a bee who asks dear Hank
and John after being a traditional
academic overachiever for the last 22
years I finally graduated college next
year I'm starting law school cuz
apparently I haven't had enough school
in my life yet but for the summer I got
my dream summer job selling popsicles
for King of Pop's it's the best I get to
hang out outside and bring people the
summer joy of tasty popsicles and hang
out with awesome coworkers but all my
friends and family act as though my
summer job is a waste of time or
unimportant in the scheme of my academic
career
my grandma even went so far as to ask
how I possibly occupying my time the
thing is I know that getting this job
was the right thing for me this summer
and I'm having an awesome time what is
your dubious advice for dealing with
people who think that you're wasting
your time just because you aren't doing
something traditionally thought of as
successful spaghetti squash and seagulls
Abbey I would anytime somebody says that
to you I would hand them a popsicle and
you say I love this so much
Abbey you're my favorite I think it's so
wonderful area around a cooler at all
times and anybody anytime somebody's
like well I can't believe your job the
summer before you go to law school is
selling popsicles and you just hand them
a popsicle and you say cute no no
obviously you say suck on this no that's
way better that's so much better and it
doesn't have to get bleeped it doesn't
have to give believed but yeah it's I
mean man first of all a bee it's so
important for us to have a variety of
experiences in our life not just the
ones that that that oh god that Kerry is
like not just that's like the shoot-down
which we are supposed to slide into into
success
like take a diversion have a good time
and and also like have a job that you
know isn't isn't constant pressure isn't
working law like being a lawyer is gonna
be hard and time like do you kind of
have to grind and work 80 hour weeks
sometimes and it is gonna know what it's
like to work for King of Pop's maybe
it's 80 hour weeks I don't know you're
right you're right maybe it's very hard
it seems it seems that it seems that
it's not
it seems that Mike my guess is that
legally king of puffs does not want you
to work into overtime hours I'm trying
to find out where we're we're king of
flops is open because I'm on their
website right now and it may be the best
designed I don't want to go back to
criticizing wedding websites but Josh
before you finish designing your wedding
website let me encourage you to check
out King of Pop's calm because this is a
fantastic website and they got a pops by
mail section and I've never even heard
of this company but a bee me either I'm
not just buying some pops although I am
I'm buying a box of pops
I am also buying a king of pops t-shirt
because they're phenomenally good
t-shirts so there's this is so cute I
love it
it's great there's a happy counter at
the top right where you can submit a
happy moment that includes a pop story
yeah give us 190 happy moments submitted
where is King of Pop's I want it I want
to open a franchise and they're well
they're committed to staying in the
south and their headquarters are in
Atlanta that's not great I'm not
I'm very saying in the South King of
Pop's why not work with me work with me
yeah we want to open up a king of pops
joint in Missoula Montana which is yeah
where for literally a month yeah but
people you know what Hank people Alaska
has per capita the most ice cream
consumption of any state in the Union is
that for real no I made it up oh it
could be true that sounded like the kind
of thing you made up it might be true
I'll tell you what this King of Pop's
website is so good I want to buy a king
of pops this is it Hank this we found
our thing we're not gonna be the people
who bring back omegas we're gonna bring
that be the people who bring King of
Pop's to Missoula that's right I want to
own
I'm gonna buy a part of King of Pop's is
that an option
who who's available meet the team yeah
can I buy I call how do I buy how do I
buy stock in this in this company that's
good to meet the team let's figure out a
lot this is a big team Stephen are you
the guy who sells me stock yeah it's a
be on the team page I don't know let's
just get it a B maybe you're not on the
team page ABI I'm not sure you should go
to law school I'm pretty sure that you
should work for king of pops for the
rest of your life
well you could go to law school and then
become like the king of pops the
in-house counsel in-house counsel great
idea Hank somebody needs to do it
they're growing fast they are I mean
look at all of these people who work at
King of Pop's I cannot wait for the King
of Pop's to open in Missoula Hank before
we get in the all-important news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon I want to read
one response from Robin who wrote in to
say hi John and Hank I was shocked when
I heard your discussion of bread heels
on the last episode of your podcast lots
of people are upset with me about my
bread Hill position I apologize the
answer to this question is so incredibly
obvious you make the sandwich with the
heel and put the crust on the inside
meaning that when you put the peanut
butter on the bread you put it on the
crust part then you have the good bread
part outside and basically you trick
your brain into thinking that you're
eating a normal sandwich it's not
stealing
it's robbing it's a great idea Robin the
idea I think that would probably work
what if you just made a sandwich with
that both the heels so you took the both
the heels you may have sand with them
and then you just pretend like it's a
calzone that's also a reasonably good
idea Hank what is the news from Mars
this week I think I know the news from
Mars and I don't think it's great it's
not great there is currently as of this
recording on Wednesday at noon a
planet-wide dust storm it is officially
surround like it is officially goes
around the whole planet so it connected
up on the other side there are some
places on the planet are not currently
inside of a dust storm but most of the
places on the planet are and and that
has included for the last like two weeks
the place where opportunity Rover is
opportunity
you landed on Mars in 2004 and it's been
continuously operational since then
though it has sad moments of outage Oh
for example during dust storm I think in
2007 that that turnt that sort of like
shut it into low power mode for a period
of time opportunity is powered by solar
panels so obviously anything that's
blocking out the Sun is bad news and
opportunity also has to have part of its
solar panels like operation is not just
to power the rover but actually like to
power a heater that keeps the rover
warmer than the surface of Mars so that
all of its stuff works
so if opportunity gets too cold it will
its batteries will not be able to
recharge it will not turn back on and
that will be the end of the opportunity
mission to be clear over 5,000 days on
Mars is a lot more than we were
expecting to get out of this thing
anyway so it's been a remarkable mission
with a lot of scientific achievement and
if this is how it goes out then that is
how it goes out but there is hope still
that it will make it through this dust
storm it's just been a very long storm
and opportunity has been in like it's
sort of fault mode where the only thing
that the battery is powering is the
internal clock hmm so that it doesn't
lose mission time nothing else is on so
it you know they're completely out of
touch with opportunity right now and it
is coming from wait and when this when
this dust storm ends and then and then
that storm will end and then after a
while all the dust particles will follow
the atmosphere those are two separate
things and then you might also have to
wait for a clean wind to come and blow
the dust off the solar panels before we
know for sure whether opportunity's
going to come back and say hi again well
it will certainly be a sad day whenever
that day comes that we lose the
opportunity Rover but it is an
incredible story I mean it's incredible
that it's been there for 15 years it's
just it's phenomenal so hopefully
there's some joy in that but it is a
very sad day if this dust storm proves
to be the end of proves to be the end of
our time with opportunity yes and John
how
a FC one of the stuff you got any new
players got any big big infusions of
cash we have not had a major infusion of
cash certain American young adult
novelists are increasing their
sponsorship that's a good piece of news
as these do have been our primary
infusion of cash of so far as that I can
see anyway there has been quite a bit of
news that the biggest news the headline
is that Lyle Taylor the great Lyle
Taylor the montserrat Ian Messi the the
legend who scored in the League Two
play-off final to help send Wimbledon
into Ligue 1 who had so many important
goals for his last season to keep us in
Ligue 1 he is moving on he has signed
for Charlton Athletic it's disappointing
because Charlton are also a league one
side and I would have liked to see Lyle
move on into the second tier of English
football if he was gonna move on from
Wimbledon that's not how it happened I
mean they certainly have a much higher
budget than Wimbledon does I'm sure that
you know and obviously you know you got
to take care of yourself during the few
years that you have as a professional
footballer he wrote a very nice letter
on Instagram in which he said it's been
the best three years of my career to
date and talked about some of both the
highs and the lows and says it's been a
real honor to play for Wimbledon to wear
the shirt and to help in this bleep last
chapter of this unique club story and I
wish everyone associated with the club
the best for the future still a huge
bummer there's no getting around it I
have to say though personally I'm so
grateful to Lyle Taylor he was always
kind to me incredibly kind to Henry when
we came and watched a game together and
it's just just a wonderful person and
obviously did so much for Wimbledon the
last three seasons and I wish him all
the best at Charlton we have gotten some
new players we also should should say
that we lost Darius Charles as well
great central defender moving on to
Wickham which is worrisome but we have
just signed in the last few
ours goalkeeper on loan from Millwall
we've had a lot of successful on loan
signings from Millwall over the years so
I'm hopeful here his name is Tom King
and that's good he has a good last name
from the perspective of you know like he
could be the king of Wimbledon's bowl
that's promising mm-hmm he wears number
13 so he's not a person who's afraid of
super he's not a superstitious man which
i think is a good sign
yep and he is a goalkeeper
unfortunately this likely means that we
are not going to have George long next
season I assume we would not be signing
Tom King if we were going to have George
long so that's another play we're gonna
have to say goodbye to but Hank I have
to get to two important signings that we
have made or three important signings
actually just in the last few days
yesterday we signed a new striker he's
30 years old his name's is James Hansen
and he has scored so many goals against
AFC Wimbledon like every time he plays
us no matter who he's playing for he
scores so hopefully he's going to keep
his good goalscoring form now that he's
playing for us he is a big guy he's a
target man we haven't had one of those
in a while so I'm excited that we've got
one I don't know what a target banner
you know like usually Wimbledon in when
they've been most successful they've had
a big person and a small person up front
like Lyle Taylor fast
Tom Elian huge auto mile Aachen phenoix
huge Lyle Taylor fast etc so I'm hopeful
for James Hansen and then we've also
signed I think almost just as important
we've got John Meads under a new
contract he's been a left back he can
also play in midfield he's really good I
like I like him a lot and I think he's a
big part of the reason we stayed up last
season so I'm feeling good about that as
well so on the whole we've lost some
players we've gained some players I mean
but the big story is wild
what what a legend he's been for
Wimbledon and he will long be remembered
in Wimbledon war John before we get to
our phrases of the week did you do your
phrase of the week I did oh shoot that's
terrible news
there we have a product for awesome
message from Heather or fothe Azzam to
Drina
Drina you are legitimately one of the
kindest people I've ever met I
mispronounced your name for a year
because you didn't want to make me feel
bad by telling me I was getting it wrong
you literally accepted a new name to be
nice I love you the same no matter what
name I may still accidentally call you
driana and I'm grateful for your
unending patience well thank you for
donating to the project for awesome and
using it to spread love that is indeed
Hank oh gosh was your phrase of the week
shirk no what was it about that act that
just popped out not sure where that came
from what was it it was Ultimate Frisbee
extravaganza wow you really did a good
job sneaking that in I wouldn't have
gotten that in a hundred years you know
what mine was mine was is really hard to
guess I have no idea king of pops
no I wish it was Gryffindor just
Gryffindor the one word it was the word
Griffin space door but I decided to
interpret it loosely hi I'm so thank you
to Phoebe for donating Gryffindor and
Hank who donated your phrase the week
thank you to grace and Scott for
donating my phrase of the week and
indeed thanks to everybody who donated
to the project for awesome this year it
meant so much to us and we're excited
for next year's p4a Hank what did we
learn today
I literally just learned that King of
Pop's was founded by two brothers oh wow
and I also learned that there is a
planet-wide dust storm on Mars which
makes it seem like a great place to
visit I learned what a target man is
let's do only things we learned in the
last five minutes and lastly I learned
that the opportunity Rover has been on
Mars
more than 5,000 days we learned so many
things jobs and make it a podcast with
me
and thanks to everybody for listening if
you want to email us you can send your
class of questions to Hank and John at
gmail.com thank you to everybody who
sends in questions because what would we
do without you except go through all of
our old podcast notes and pull out the
ones that we didn't answer and we
probably pull out the wrong ones because
I can't remember anything that happened
more than five minutes ago that didn't
make any sense but thanks for Prodigy's
me this podcast is edited by nicholas
jenkins it's produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno the music that you are
listening to right now and at the
beginning of the podcast is by the great
gunnarolla we are now off to make our
patreon only podcast this weekend rience
it's terrible you should listen to it
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
thank you again for listening and as
they say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
[Music]